we all know that in the S phase of the
cell cycle DNA replication takes place
right and replication initiation takes
place at the very transition state from
g1 to s but have you ever imagined
that in this one cell cycle time why the
replication does not take place twice
let's say one round of replication after
that
why does another round of replication
does not take place think of
transcription transcription can go on
and on multiple times right but why
can't replication go on on and on well
clearly you can understand that if
replication goes on on and on you would
have n 2 n 4n and that's how your
promise on number would increase so
clearly you have to think about the
ploidy as well isn't it fascinating that
how really cell ensures that the event
of replication takes place only once
during one cell cycle in this video
we'll talk about the molecular
mechanisms the details of how cell
really regulates this process and what
is the importance of it and exactly the
genetic factors that is governing this
process so still stay tuned till the end
of this video if you haven't yet
subscribe hit that subscribe button now
really this question was bothering
scientists for about twenty years that
why replication takes place only once
during the cell cycle what people
thought that okay the components which
are allowing the replication to happen
such as the origin of replication
complex that is only present in the S
phase not any other phase that's why
scientists took samples from several
phases of the cell cycle and they can
obtain several phases of cell cycle by
using several inhibitors that are not
talking about right now but they
collected protein samples or the
cellular extracts from
cell cycle phases and then they run that
on a jail while they probed for the
origin of replication complex which is
absolutely essential for replication to
initiate they found something striking
they thought that only one particular
phase that is a yes phase there would be
the expression of these origin of
replication of origin of replication but
it turns out at every phase that they
have collected sample from have these
oversee complex and this was pretty
confusing to them at that moment that
hope in what what is the alternative
mechanism it took at least forty years
to understand that now it turns out all
of the phases have their DNA bound to or
C complex but selectively at S phase the
or C complex initiate that replication
right not in any other phases how does
that happen
so we are right now at the end of a
mitotic division it's a beginning of the
g1 phase and over C is found to be
associated with the DNA now several
components such as series 6 C T t1 all
of these gets associated with the over C
complex along with that MCM helicases
gets associated now we know that at S
phase starting point the replication
also starts so beyond this G 1 point
something really need to give a go
signal which would allow the replication
to start and a replication bubble to
form
it turns out the SFA cycling's which are
produced late g1 and picks in the S
phase they are the ones which said which
would give the go signal so s-phase
cyclin phosphorylate several components
of this origin of replication complex it
phosphorylates CTD CD c6 and also MCM 27
right as a result the replication can
initiate in technical term it means
origin of replication complex firing now
it is ready to start the process of
replication and the start signal is
given by s phase cycling city complexes
which are cycling Ian's cdk2 right now
after that what happens is the CTD one
and CDC six just after it is
phosphorylated that was the trigger
point when the replication started they
would dissociate from the complex from
the RC complex or C itself would fall
off well while the replication bubble is
created now this MCM helicase is
actually unwind the Strand and other
enzymes are allowing the replication to
progress smoothly forming the
replication bubble to sort of expand and
creating new DNA strands but soon after
the replication bubble is progressing in
the both sides you can see the origin of
replication complex again in E again
attached to the newly synthesized
strands newly synthesized tourists and
strands but the problem is replication
does not restart or cv just get bind to
the DNA in a repetitive fashion but
replication does not take place in a
repetitive fashion how does it happens
it turns out that CD 1 and series 6
which are basically this starting signal
or the trigger
actors which would allow the origin
firing cannot bind to the war see again
if they are phosphorylated question is
who is maintaining their phosphorylation
state throughout the other phase of cell
cycle turns out at the end of S phase at
the end of his face once I clean comes
up which is cycling P which pairs with
cdk1
and at psyche and mitotic phase at the
end of g2 phase it really picks up their
concentration right so the cyclin b c d
k 1 complex otherwise known as
maturation promoting factor complex they
can maintain the phosphorylation state
of series 6 and c td 1 ensuring that
they cannot bind to or see any more
further ensuring her replication
initiation scenario does not repeat that
is why replication initiation takes only
once and only once in the cell cycle now
the question is still when the cyclin b
c d k1 would maintain this phosphoryl
phosphorylation level till death till
the cycling beyond cdk1 complex is there
right it turns out at the beginning of
the g1 phase cycling b and cdk1 complex
its inactivated because the cycling B is
degraded so nobody is there to maintain
this phosphorylation level but at the
point of time the opposing force the for
the phosphatases are active which works
upon c td 1 and c d c6 d phosphorylate
them once they are D phosphorylated they
can reassociate with the or C again so
in the next round of division another
replication event can take place here by
we can understand that by stringently
monitoring the phosphorylation level of
these triggering factors such as CTD 1
and city 6 cyclin be silica complex and
phosphatases play hand-in-hand to ensure
that replication
is restricted to one narrow time window
which is the s-phase and does not
restart in other phases of the cell
cycle and that is how cell avoids its
detrimental consequences that is how
beautiful cell has designs its strategy
to ensure and duplicates ifsta nomic
material so I hope you enjoyed this
video and the main part that we have
discussed in this video is the S phase
the association of the phosphorylation
phosphorylation takes place and the S
phase they first associate then the
phosphorylation takes place right but in
other phases they cannot associate
because they are already in a
phosphorylated state they need to be
first is phosphorylated and then refers
for elated in order to start another
round of replication but the situation
which is created by these high cleans
does not allow to do so that is why this
replication is restricted to the S phase
so I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you